The advantage of a challenge is that
you're saying, okay, for the next
30 days or for the next 90 days, I'm
gonna push myself a little further.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Uh, today I wanna talk about the next
series of challenges at LingQ, 90-Day
Challenges or 30 Day Challenges.
Remember, if you enjoy these videos,
please subscribe, click on the bell for
notifications, and if you follow me on a
podcast service, please leave a comment.
So, uh, I have been involved in a
number of language challenges at LingQ.
Why do I do it and why do I think
it's a good idea for, for learners
to push themselves in this way?
Um, you know, one of the main issues,
in fact I've said before that the,
the with language learning is a
function of, of attitude and of
time, time spent with a language.
Uh, so attitude.
A large part of attitude is
of course our motivation.
How keen we are.
And in an ideal world, every day
we wake up and we just can't wait
to start learning our language.
We can't wait to listen.
We can't wait to read, and we're happy and
everything is, you know, on the up and up.
Unfortunately, that's not always the case.
There are days when we don't
feel like listening to our,
whatever we're listening to.
There are days when we're discouraged,
when we're busy, we invent all kinds of
reasons why we needn't bother, and yet
we know that, you know, staying with it.
This idea of continuity is so
important to language learning.
Even a little bit every day is gonna keep
us moving in the direction of fluency
or whatever, you know, our goal is.
So that's one of the reasons why at
LingQ we have a number of sort of,
call it tricks to keep people going.
Uh, the statistics in
themselves are motivating.
They're motivating to motivating to me.
How many words have I read?
How many words have I saved?
In other words, how many
LingQs have I created?
How many hours have I listened?
When I look back in my profile page,
and I see when I started and when
I was active and how active I've
been over the last little period
all of this is motivating to me.
So the statistics are in themselves
motivating, but the advantage of a
challenge is then you're saying, okay, for
the next 30 days or for the next 90 days,
I'm gonna push myself a little further.
And one of the things that I think the
LingQ team has done that's, that's really
good now is that whereas before you had to
have, you know, you had specific targets.
Like you had to save so many words.
In other words, create so many LingQs
uh, you had to read so many words,
you had to listen so many hours.
There are very specific, you know,
activity related, uh, targets.
And that's a bit unfair because, you
know, as I often say, you wanna keep
doing the things that you enjoy doing.
So some days you're more
inclined to listen or maybe
you only have time to listen.
Some other days you're
more inclined to read.
Maybe you're reading material
that you've already gone through.
Some other day, you're going
through new materials, so you're,
you're creating new LingQs.
And so by kind of
merging, funging, every...
every activity into the, the concept
of coins, as long as you maintain the
target you've set for coins, uh, which
you can do in a variety of different
ways, you are able to maintain a streak.
So not only is the target important
and the idea that you're committed,
30 or a 90 day, uh, challenge
important, but I found this desire
to maintain my street kept me going.
And so you wanna be careful that you
set a level in terms of the coins per
day that is sufficiently challenging
without being too difficult, so
that it's kind of, you're pushing
yourself, but it's not too easy.
And if you're able to do that, then you
get a great sense of sense of satisfaction
because we know that the brain, if the
brain is confronted with a task that's
a little difficult and is able to do it,
there is a great sense of satisfaction.
If the task is too easy, then there
is very little stimulus from that.
If the task is so difficult that we
simply can't maintain that level of
activity, then it's discouraging.
So it's important to choose a level
that that works for you, that pushes
you without being too difficult and
occasionally I, what I do, if I fall
behind and I lose my streak, then I'm
able to take the coins that I've earned
and use them to repair my streak.
So if I, if I have a streak of 30
days, and then for whatever reason
now I wasn't able to do anything, the
next day I'm able to repair my streak
so that I now have a 31, 32, 33.
And just keep that streak going.
So, you know, and some of us may
be into several languages, so
that's a bit of a disadvantage that
you can't merge across languages.
So the solution there is to set, not
to tough a target in each of two or
three languages so that you're able to
maintain your activity in those languages.
And so, uh, let's say, Uh, gonna
have a tougher sort of goal in, say,
in my case, Persian and a somewhat
lower goal in Arabic and Turkish.
Then I don't have to spend a lot of
time on the minor languages to maintain
that lesser, you know, goal, maintain
my streak, but at least I'm staying
in touch with those languages while I
focus more effort on my main language.
So check the, uh, uh, challenges at LingQ.
Commit yourself to a challenge.
You'll be happy you did.
And then you can follow how other
LingQ members are doing by going to
the community page and seeing who,
you know, who has the longest streak,
who has, uh, you know, created the
most LingQs and so forth and so on.
So it's, it's a fun way to connect
with others, which also is important
in language learning, because sometimes
we can feel that it's a bit of a lonely
activity, but once we realize we're part
of a larger community  that, uh, are
working on whatever language it might be,
the language you're learning or some other
language, you can see the sort of, uh,
level of activity in different languages.
I find that quite motivating.
So with that, I would encourage you
to get involved here in the new year
in, uh, some kind of a challenge,
30 or 90 days push yourself.
Not so hard that you can't keep up,
but not so easy that you don't really
feel that you've achieved very much.
So best of luck to you on your challenges
and uh, you'll see in these, uh,
videos that I'll leave with you that
I have had challenges in a number of
languages and it has pushed me forward.
So good luck to you.
Bye for now.